nigeria tests out new equipment
soon to be deployed at sea it's an
arsenal of ground
air and sea vessels and equipment
designed to tackle
pirates operating in the gulf of guinea
attacks in the region have grown in
number
and sophistication over the past five
years
it's very difficult to eradicate it but
our target
is to see a zero tolerance
of maritime insecurity within and beyond
our own territorial waters
we have a complete garment
of land
air and sea approach of
assets that can handle the issue of this
insecurity
countries in the region lose nearly a
billion dollars annually to pirate
attacks
many are carried out in nigerian waters
many countries in west africa
and the gulf of guinea have tied their
maritime security to that of the
continent's
biggest economy and for good reason a
significant number of the 32 attacks
carried out
in the first quarter of 2021 happened in
nigeria's territorial waters
ship operators hope with the country's
deployment of additional vessels
like this 17 interceptor boats 10
aircraft including drones
will help to keep the number down
in addition to the loss of lives and
equipment many businesses have closed
there was a time in this country that we
had
almost 200 fleets
deep sea fishing trawlers but due to the
activities of this
free piracy and the various attacks
a lot of businesses have either fizzled
out
or relocated to neighboring
countries and she says getting them back
will be hard as new threats are emerging
we have cultures that come from
europe and asian countries i mean
they're steal our natural resources
and they take the natural resources in
the most
irresponsible unregulated manner
ship operators navigating the gulf of
guinea now pay insurance premiums
similar to what's paid by those in war
zones
forcing some to avoid the region
altogether
officials in nigeria hope the improved
security force
will restore confidence in merchants to
once again
ply the gulf of guinea ahmedi trees al
jazeera
lagos